hey guys my name is Jessa McDonald it is
a 15th October today and the show you're
watching is gamespot news if you like
Xbox and Assassin's Creed but for some
reason have neither the newest iteration
of either of those then Microsoft have
just the thing for you leaked earlier
this week by Austrian retailer game
where Microsoft has announced two
Assassin's Creed themed Xbox one bundles
one more run you 399 bucks and includes
the console plus digital copies of AC
unity and AC 4 black flag while the
second goes for 499 dollars and also
includes a Kinect and a copy of Dance
Central spotlight if you want one
they're on sale from November 2 although
you will need to wait until November 11
to actually play unity since that's when
it's released publicly heading over to
the Sony side of the fence someone's
making custom peaceful laptops for some
reason self-taught engineer adds Eric
who's also responsible for the Xbox one
and laptop mashup named X book has
created the world's first playbook for
pure gamer first delivered the details
on this one which amounted to the ps4
innards being refitted inside a 3d
printed and laser-cut plastic case the
Box bits are attached to a 22 inch vizio
1080p LED LCD screen which pops up in
the lid if you're starting to consider
it you should probably know that
ordering a playbook full will put you
thirteen hundred and ninety-five bucks
out of pockets although it's $300 less
if you provide the ps4 plus shipping you
can however choose the color of your
PlayBook for from a variety of colors
and dark adds then you can do a full
graphic customization for extra dough if
you want and finally we have a
resolution story with a happy ending
since killer instinct on Xbox one is set
to get a rest boost the second season of
the free-to-play fighting game brings
with it new features customizations
content and a resolution jump from 720p
to 900p according to the studio's
community manager Killer Instinct
requires you to buy characters and you
can either purchase them for five bucks
a piece
I'll get the eight fighter inclusive
combo break
a pack for $20 the first four confirmed
characters for the second season RTG
combo Maya rip jaw and cinder the second
season also brings a new user interface
which is supposed to be quicker and
consists of better statistic tracking
while the existing character roster has
supposedly been rebalanced as your
version of the day let me know if you
would want a playbook for if you're
after more news you bits and pieces so
you can get stories on fire cry 3.5 and
call of duty advanced warfare on
GameSpot that is it for me today thanks
for checking in as always and I will
catch you tomorrow